today i think we'll speak a little bit
about you know my drug uh
habit the ways to deal drugs you know i
mean the west be around drugs
how i got introduced to them you know i
mean what i started with you know
i always hear a lot of people say they
started with marijuana you know what
me myself i didn't have that luxury you
know uh
me and my little brother one time where
we were getting out of school or
we're real young we're about maybe about
11 and 12 you know we ran into some
older dudes and they were right there
and
i remember we walked up you know i seen
the first guy he was
holding onto the wall and he wasn't
moving and i was like hey what did he
smoke you know
so the other dude says hey well you know
i got it right here you know me so he
brought out this glass bottle
a pack of cool cigarettes and uh what he
did was he stuck the cigarette inside
and he turned the cigarette he blew it
backwards
and he blew all the liquid into the
cigarette and he told me this is a 20
dip right here this is pcp
so i wanted to be curious to see what it
did to you so
we end up smoking it now we were 12 and
11 years old
remember me and my little brother smoked
it in i remember the feeling of uh
being like as strong as like as strong
as like 10 guys you know
it made me feel like i was strong like
for 10 guys you know you know
so we smoked it you know i mean the next
day i went back and my little brother
and i
told the dude hey man let me buy ten
dollars worth you know so he ended
dipping one he gave it to us
we went and smoked it and uh we didn't
go home for two days you know
right after that i noticed once we
smoked that pcp you know
we were already getting interested in in
marijuana and weed you know
we used to see my father deal with his
drugs but he was dealing with heroin and
i remember i used to hear them talk
about it
back then it was a quarter spoon 25
and you would get high one time and you
would be high
all day until the night time you know
what i mean he only got down one time
reason i know because i was with him you
know so i used to watch my father you
know
deal his little heroine but he also sell
weed on the side you know what i mean
and we were
interested in the weed well i had a
friend down the street
and his dad used to move a lot of weed
you know he was one of the main weed
connections
so you know i wanted to get you know i
wanted to get in the weed and see what
it was about so
one day me and my friend were at his dad
at his house and i tell me now your
dad's not here won't you go see if
there's anything in his stash
so he goes in there he comes out and he
brings out i say about two ounces of
weed
good weed you know what i tell man
that's a lot you're that ain't gonna
notice
he's like no i fixed it the same way and
everything so we had school the next day
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
take it to school
i'm gonna be cool self you dime sell
some joints you know what i mean and i
thought i had it together
went to school took it in my backpack we
smoked one joint before we went you know
i mean
it was like the third time i had smoked
weed so we smoked a joint i was already
nervous going to school but i went
anyways
when i got there you know i kept
smelling the fragrance of weed
when i was young i didn't realize that
the weed was coming out
the back of my backpack the smell and i
didn't realize that till we went to the
bathroom my little brother
said you smell like weed so we opened it
up we ended up wrapping it with some
paper towels
some more plastic and we put it back in
the backpack and
uh they decided they wanted to go up to
the field
so i was like okay let's go so we went
up to the field and we're up there
and i remember getting the weed i put it
on my lap and get some rolling papers
out and
mind you i'm really learning how to roll
but i'm about to roll a joint
and i hear hey can i look up man it's
the principle man
we're understanding grade and the
principal just caught me with an ounce
of weed
he walks up he grabs the weed where'd
you get this at you know i mean
i said i found it you know he's like no
you didn't where'd you get it who sold
it to you so now he wants to call my
parents and
you know my mother she wouldn't say
nothing my father he's gonna get a
little upset but
he already knows i'm doing something he
asked me like
a couple weeks before i was smoking weed
i denied it
but uh now it's gonna come out the truth
and i'm really scared man cause my
father he was
he was a nice guy but when he got mad he
got really mad you know what i mean and
i know how mad he was gonna be
that i got caught with weed you know but
kind of surprised me when he came you
know he came in
he talked to the principal he came back
out and he didn't tell me nothing
he didn't tell me nothing on the way
when we get home and we stop he parks
the car and he tells me uh
you know you're kicked out of school
right i'm like
yeah i got suspended you know what's the
big deal he says no you got kicked out
of
school you got kicked out of the whole
school district and i was like
for wheat they caught me with wheat he
said no well you did a lot of things
leading up to this
this was just the one that icebreaker
and now you're kicked out of school
so i was 12 years old and i was kicked
out of the whole school district i
didn't know where to go to school so
i used to go in the afternoon to about
three houses down i had one of my homies
over there
and um i know his dad used to move a lot
of cocaine you know back in the 80s and
stuff
but i wasn't aware that my homie was
still moving cocaine for his father
well since i didn't go to school i used
to go to his house in the morning and
i would always see his father go in the
room and he'll do something in there and
then he'd come out with a bag of
i don't know what it was i found out
after it was this bag of all cocaine
he had nothing but uh keys in there you
know what i mean and i didn't know the
dad was doing it that big until
we went in the attic and found his stash
you know we went in the attic we're
looking around we ended up opening up a
suitcase
and there was so much coke in there it
looked like i felt like i was in a movie
there was so much coke you know it might
have been like
there was like i think i counted 16
bricks
of coke and they were all keys you know
and my friend was going to take one and
i said oh you take one he'll notice you
know that's too big of an issue you know
so
there was one to the side that was open
it had a little spoon on it
and um i remember looking at it and and
it looked real yellow you know and i
didn't know what it was at that time but
what it was it was peruvian flake
it was coming from florida his dad was
hooked up with a dude and
well anyways we took some of it but we
took about i'd say about
maybe at maybe a half ounce we took we
had in the big sandwich baggie
and then went to motor homies and of
course we had to pay him
but we told him hey can you quarter
these up because back then they
sell you a binder it was shaped like an
envelope
and it was 25 you know no matter what 25
not 23 not 22 25
and you get a quarter of coke now the
coke i had was really really good so
by this time you know what i mean this
this a year had passed and we were doing
different things with weed but then we
got into the coke scene
and i noticed that the coke scene you
know
there was a lot of people from mexico
that liked the cocaine you know they
used to call it perico i used to see
them and
you know these dudes used to have little
vials with little spoons on it you know
and
all of them had a long ass pinky ring i
mean a pinky uh
a nail you know your nails like that
long i used to wonder why they had long
long nails until they broke a bottle out
one time and all of them were using
their pinky nails to
sniff coke you know what i mean and i
thought that that kind of you know
represent them you know because all of
them had a long pinking alien
i used to go to them and i used to sell
them in their bar and you know
these dudes always had money man they
never came short you know i mean
they always had the money you know the
only thing that that irritated me was
every time i took them coke they wanted
me to bring them a woman now i wasn't
into pimping and bringing women and all
this stuff but
they bought me so much that i had two
homegirls and my hungers were game for
anything they wanted to make money so i
took them over there
i got into the coke scene and when i got
into the coke scene
i was already getting into the gangs so
when i was in the gangs and i was in the
coke scene i was dealing coke
the next thing i know i'm sitting in a
two-bedroom house
you know what i mean that's big backyard
big front yard
and i'm having a barbecue there and i
remember you know my uncle tells his
friend you know uh
they asked whose house he was and he
told him it was mine
and it made me feel good you know being
i was about maybe 15 by this time you
know i was
moving a lot of coke i mean i was moving
so much where my home used to come by
every night and drop me off ounce of
coke you know and i used to make
bendo after bend after bed until my
actually my hands hurt
you know what i mean and then i started
noticing that
from me touching the coke you know for
you the ones that don't know you know
that stuff soaks in your pores
you know it's like the fat in all the
day you know you get it
and you break it and then once you put
it down
it's stuck all on your fingers you know
there's no way you can
scrape it off with a knife dust it off
with your hands
no there's no way it stays on your
fingers the only way you get it off that
i've noticed
is you rub it into your pores and from
me dealing that coke way back then i
used to always feel
you know awake you know not really alive
but awake you know and
smoke cigarette after cigarette and i
wasn't touching the coke what i was
doing was i was selling it but
i had my little homie dealing with me
and he was a big coke head you know i
mean he used to bring me story after
story
with with the drug addiction and and
people doing drugs i noticed that they
will tell you anything
anything you want to hear they'll give
you the shirt off their back they'll
promise
you a check next week you know what i
mean and it just goes
on and on and on that's why they never
say never front anybody
but the thing about it is that you know
for an individual like myself that uses
drugs
you know um when i would be when i would
be sick
from heroin i would do a lot of things i
wouldn't do
in my normal frame of mind you know rob
somebody steal something you know i
wouldn't do that in my right frame of
mind
but being strung out you know uh there
was things i would do that i wouldn't do
necessarily today you know i mean there
was games i would run on people
just to get their money you know just so
i would have my wake up you know and it
was always
worried about the wake up because you
know that's like the only drug i could
remember that
from the addiction came a sickness
you know like i said i went through the
coke i didn't get sick went to the pcp
didn't get sick the weed used to get
paranoid but never sick
but the heroin you know when i first
heard about it i was like
i was 15 and my homie tells me you want
to slam
and i'm like i'm only 15 years old and
i'm like do i want to slam
wow you know my father's been slamming
all his life i've been watching it all
this time all my uncle slammed
you know in my head i actually thought
that that's what
i'm supposed to do i'm supposed to slam
heroin go to prison
run around my homies and and if they're
getting killed when i'm dead
killed when i'm young or they'll tell
them an old man and stay
with the gangster mentality the troll
mentality you know
whatever anybody calls it the thug
mentality stayed with that all my life
you know and at that age when i was 15
my homie tells me if i wanted to slam
some heroin
and i was like yeah he said well give me
some of that coke and i'm like will you
do the cookie because i'm gonna put the
coke with the heroin
so he wants to slam a speed ball no i've
never ever did it before and i'm kind of
nervous because man he's
putting a lot of coke inside that heroin
and he draws up and he tells me all
right let me see your arm you know and i
remember exactly what happened you know
i got about tied it around my arm and he
injected me i took off the bow
and i remember i got this this rush this
i mean this rush that it feels like it
rushes so fast it feels like somebody
grabs your top your head just
rips your skull back you know it just
feels like that you know i don't know
what the name of it but it's so much of
a rush that
it feels like they grab you and just
peel you back you know every
hair on your neck stands up and then
stuff that you hear like you turn the
water faucet on it sounds like there's a
waterfall
everything's just totally loud like the
water's
you know just totally loud in your ears
and then about
five minutes through all sudden you feel
a warmness come on
it's like eating it's like being in the
cold and then getting a big old blanket
and putting
it around you that's the best example i
can give you of heroin
you you like getting a blanket you're in
the cold and you get a blanket you put
it around you
you know that feeling of oh that's how
heroin feels
like to me it feels like you get a
blanket and you just wrap yourself with
it feels like you're encased you're warm
you know and then
every pain in your body is gone every
ache in pain is gone i know a guy who's
in the hospital that shattered both his
legs
he was screaming at the top of his lungs
when i got adam and i told him i had
something
that would make him stop screaming
believe me he stopped screaming
but the only thing he picked up a habit
too you know something that
you know i wouldn't invite anybody he
picked up but he picked up a hero and
had heroin have it
and he went to afghanistan war and all
that he was one of my friends he had
episodes and all that but when he was
with me
and he was on heroin he never had an
episode but his legs were shattered he
had all kinds of problems because
he wasn't on drugs he did it on a sound
mind you know
i think he got caught up in afghanistan
and he gets flashbacks and [ __ ] but i
noticed when he was with me
he never had a flashback he's just like
with my homie when he used to get high
with me
he never had problems but when he got
high alone he had problems
this is the same one that me and him
dealt coke together now as we're dealing
with coke i'd say on 15 i go to camp i
get back
out low and behold i go visit my
grandmother in norwalk
i got two cousins from norwalk right
there that's our grandma's house
i walked in the house about 12 in the
afternoon my aunt tells me you know the
[ __ ] out here
i don't want this [ __ ] [ __ ] in here i
don't know who brought this [ __ ] in here
i go in there getting a pcp everywhere
of course i grab my issue go to the hood
start selling it the guy we belong to
now he's looking for me and my homie he
wants to know where the hell we're at
because we took
a good amount of his juice i say about 5
000
worth of his juice you know i mean
that's a lot of money back then you know
it was like about 90 we took it 89.90
mind yours back then and we took it we
took a whole duffel bag full
and we had a bumper-to-bumper we had
foods all
juiced out on the curb you know i mean
foods would stay there all night
inside their car you know what i mean so
we had to change that you know the hood
started getting hot you know i mean food
started
calling us through the car to pick and
then shoot at us you know so we're being
careful you know because
we're selling juice right there but we
got to watch the guys that call us to
the car because that was one of the
tricks back then he'll call you to the
car and then
shoot you dead you know so even though
we got the juice you know we ain't
smoking it but everybody else is
high as hell we graduated from juice
they brought us some angel dust now when
i seen the angel dress
it was a square tinfoil and it was so
small and i was like man what is this
it's ten dollars an angel does
so i go and i open it up what do you do
you roll it like a joint
so i rolled it like a joint now andrew
does is a feeling
of total invincibility
like no one can [ __ ] with you at all i'm
talking about
you become just that guy if you think
you know karate
you can perform karate kung fu whatever
i know i've experienced with it where i
smoked the duster
i thought i was a karate guy and whipped
this dude's ass with a gang of kicks and
[ __ ]
but it was just the drug that induced my
mind thinking
that i was actually a kung fu fighter
you know no karate i mean
it's it's a feeling where the dust
is the same thing it warms you up you
get a rush but you just feel invincible
you know what i mean and you don't want
anybody telling you [ __ ]
nothing and it's called angel does but
they changed the name to kukui dust
because of the fact that the dust that
my homie was making
was black and original dust is green or
brown
my homie had black dust so they called
the kakui dust and this dust right here
i say one joint four people would
sit down and wouldn't you stand back up
you know what i mean i like the dust so
i wanted to actually make the dust
myself so i said you know what
[ __ ] this i'm paying this dude to make
it this dude to [ __ ] hold it
i'm eliminate all that [ __ ] i'ma make it
i'ma hold it i'ma sell it i'm gonna
collect all the money
so that's what i did i got in my brother
and it's home look i want you to teach
me how to cook
dust how to make it he's oh man you
don't want to i said yes i do man i want
to make dust
so he went got a big pickle jar emptied
all the pickles out cleaned it real good
he went we went to compton we bought a a
300 pour we went to the market and we
bought mint leaves
you know they come in a little can you
know we bought about four cans of mint
leaves
we got home he got the he got the big
old jug
he threw mint leaves in there he threw
like half the juice in there
and he shook the bottle around you know
and all that he was getting wet and it
got all stuck to the sides
and he got it and you open the freezer
boom stuck it in the freezer boom
close it about hour two later we take it
out take a little bit out roll it let it
dry roll it
smoke it and we're smoking it to see
how potent we could get it you know but
we're
we're our own test dummies you know but
the way we did it was
i would smoke once then he would smoke
the next one because if we smoke the
smoke to smoke
we wouldn't even know how good was the
stuff by the time we get it and take it
out so
we did it like that the first batch we
made i remember the first batch we made
we made 300 each and that's selling just
dimes you know and that's
fresh you know one thing about selling
drugs when you get to a spot
you have to make that spot yours you
have to make it known that that's you
you know you can't let anybody else come
in and just deal because the fact that
they're stepping on your toes you know
there are sometimes where we used to
rotate there's four of us there we're
all selling drugs
okay first customer second customer
third customer fourth customer
and that's how we should do it we used
to rotate it you know because there are
places where
there's enough traffic and enough money
for seven [ __ ] to deal right
there
but it's just that a lot of people are
greedy a lot of people are jealous they
don't feel that there's enough for
everybody
they want it all for themselves and i
learned that with the drug trade where
you know um you can give a guy a whole
pound of weed
the next day you might ask him to let
you borrow 20
and in the game in the drug game
nothing's free
no one rides for free they may think
they got you high and it was for free
but i guarantee you a week or two later
to be like hey you got that money
what money i remember the other day when
i got you higher
okay you got me high where is it that
you
sold this to me but since it's a
drugging and it's
through and through you you gotta pay to
do the money because you own for the
drug you know but
they don't necessarily tell you hey i'm
i'm charging you for what i'm getting
you high on
i was a strong believer and if i tell
you i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you
high you gotta bring no money just bring
yourself
but there's dudes out there that get you
high and then they wanna charge you
after and
that's where a lot of jams come up
behind the drug game the drug game
a lot of dudes will sell you drugs and
then sell you drugs and sell drugs and
then one day
they swear they gave you the package but
you know you never got it
but it's his word against yours now he's
the one with all the dog he's the one
that been supplying
for me to pay my rent what am i supposed
to do what am i going to tell them
i just end up gonna agree with him take
it as a lot
and pay him again for what he never gave
me
you know and and what could i do i mean
i don't have it on camera i don't have
nothing down on writing i
take no picture i can't sue this guy for
not giving me my dope
so that would be the second thing and
that would be getting yourself into
[ __ ] like that
and i'll be the first one to say doing
drugs
is a [ __ ] hard-ass job people don't
look at it like a job but it's so
[ __ ] hard
that first thing in the morning when you
wake up that's the first thing in your
head
the second thing is where are you going
how far are you going to travel
because me i'll travel anywhere if it's
good though i don't give a [ __ ] i'll go
wherever
and you know either you have to go far
or you would have to wait
[ __ ] hours and hours and i didn't
like to do that i wanted it on hand
so i used to tell my homies if we could
get it all here on hand then we won't
have to want from anybody else
they'll start wanting from us so i
learned in the drug game
if you're going to get there sit there
and deal drugs
you have to buy everybody out around you
or either bring them in with you
because it's not going to work everybody
trying to
get everybody's clientele people get
confused you know
dude just start lowballing you you know
you'll be selling something for 10
and dude come and see i got it for seven
you know see now he's lowballing you you
know he's going to get your money that
you're supposed to get for this dude
but dude rather pay seven keep a couple
of bucks for a sold or something instead
of giving
maybe the whole ten but there are guys
like that
there are those kind of drug dealers
that they go wherever and whenever and
just slide right in
and start selling their drug until they
get caught there's another [ __ ]
that puts dope out there but he puts
laxatives
inside it so when you do it you sit on
the [ __ ] for like two days
[ __ ] water you know what i mean but
this dude only does it like every four
months
he'll put a bad child and then he'll
pull it back i guess he just makes money
and then he'll pull it back
and that [ __ ] dope is so [ __ ] up
you know that's another thing you gotta
you gotta do when you when you're doing
that job being a drug dealer getting
high
is you got to make sure that drugs are
good and you have to check the shelf
life
but you can sell you a pound right now
and you put it up in your closet
and two days later the [ __ ] turned into
plastic on you so you have to
go and know how much shelf like does it
have how long is it gonna last
how long do i have to get off this
before this [ __ ] starts getting weak or
starts getting bad
a lot of people don't look at that they
don't ask the question they go
is it good yeah it's good let me try it
oh yeah it's good as hell
how good is it going to be in two or
three days that's the question you have
to ask yourself
that's the one thing i see a lot of
so-called drug dealers do
they do not ask how much shelf life
does this have that's one of the most
key
things in drug dealing is making sure
you know how much shelf like these
[ __ ] [ __ ] gods
because i seen this [ __ ] that was bomb
ass [ __ ]
top of the grade um ice the next day was
[ __ ] hard like [ __ ] rubber cement
in a bag just from sitting on a shelf
it turned into hard-ass plastic but the
night before
was smoking boy after the ball doing
lying homie was poking stuff and the
[ __ ] was bomb
so you have to remember the shelf life
you know a lot of people say they got
good as [ __ ]
but the [ __ ] doesn't stay long it's like
nowadays
you use heroin and to tell you the truth
it's a waste of time because
there's no more heroin inside the heroin
there might be 30 percent in there
but that ain't [ __ ] everything else is
fentanyl
sugar and amphetamines
you know pills you know they're putting
pills in there
they're putting [ __ ] uh fentanyl in
there
you know they put coffee in there
chocolate you know
they cut it with all kinds of experiment
with all kinds of [ __ ]
but the one who's getting [ __ ] is the
one buying it
see i'm buying it putting it in my veins
and that's the whole thing about
the drug trade a [ __ ] could hand
you a balloon
you don't even know what's in it but
you'll open it up and put a spoon and
cook it up and slam it you don't even
know what's in the [ __ ] spoon
but you already gave your money away
dude i gave it to you and you're so
you're so [ __ ] up in your your your
addiction where you ain't even
really worried about what's in there
i've had [ __ ] turn purple
and i still slammed it and the [ __ ]
turned purple
i put it in there and then the ring and
it turned [ __ ] purple on
[ __ ] it i went with it you know that
that's the type of mentality that i had
ever since i was young
with the pcp that i started with [ __ ] it
started selling coke
[ __ ] it he means started selling dust
[ __ ] it i always just say
[ __ ] it you know i'm gonna sell as much
as i can you know what i mean but see i
was the type of drug dealer where i
never used the scale
and i always felt that if i don't use a
scale
i'm going to give you what you're
satisfied with and what i'm satisfied
giving you
so now we both walk away happy but you
also walk away with knowing the back of
your head that if you go to him
he's going to give you a point for a
point if you come to me i'ma give you
some what you're paying for and some
so guys are going to come to me other
guys get mad but
they don't want to do that they don't
want to fork up a little bit
you know like make us make like a small
sacrifice in the beginning to get that
large reward in the end
a lot of these guys don't look at it in
the future they only look at it
right then and there you know what i
mean and
drugs come and drugs go you got drugs
you're the dealer
you got [ __ ] running to the
store getting you soda
getting you water and you got a [ __ ]
rubbing your feet
trying to braid your hair i mean they
they're doing everything because
you got the biggest sack but let a
[ __ ] walk in with more
that whole crowd would just shift right
to him without even a second thought of
oh we left this guy no conscience
whatsoever i noticed now that the phenom
does that
i mean myself i don't [ __ ] with fed no i
don't encourage anybody to
but you have to remember that that no
it's uncontrollable you know i mean once
you od on it
it's very very hard to bring you back i
know i've brought in individuals back
maybe six total on fentanyl and
i hit him with narcan i didn't do a
[ __ ] thing
hit him again with a narcan not a
[ __ ] thing
after the third or fourth hit of narcan
they start coming too
with heroin one hit an arcade you're
back and you jump up
feeding on you slowly get up
then once you get up you want to lay
back down because you have to lay back
down they just give you narcan
some guys think oh i slammed fell out
gave me narcan
i'ma get up and i'm gonna slam again no
you could slam your whole [ __ ] batch
and you ain't gonna feel
[ __ ] narcan along with
suboxone have what you call a blocker
they block off so your
uh your um with heroin when you're
you you induce your uh
i can't get the word right now but
there's some type of
thing in your brain that endorphins you
release endorphins
and the only other way they say you can
release that kind of endorphins
is with total total excitement but like
uncontrollable excitement
you can release endorphins and feel the
same way you feel when you're on heroin
and i always heard aaron was the main
thing here when i got into heroin yeah
in the beginning
it was the main thing you know it it
used to be good
to get high in heroin used to feel good
running around feeling good
once you get used to doing heroin and
you get strung out
it's no longer about getting high
anymore it's about
getting straight getting well you know
and some guys get well on a dime
some guys take some a whole gram to get
well you know what i mean
i'm a type individual i'm just going to
do some then a little more than a little
more because you can always do more
but you can never take off if you do too
much you're just [ __ ]
so i always encourage people hey just do
half then do the other half then the
other half
don't do the whole [ __ ] thing because
you once you put in your vein you can't
take off no more it's all there you know
what i mean and
i know just recently i od
and when i od'd i knew i was going to od
so i told my ex-girlfriend get the
narcan
and that's all i said when i woke up
came two i was already we were walking
around
but it's just that i knew
that i was going to hold dean and the
reason i knew i was you know did because
i actually felt like somebody grabbed
the back of my head
and was trying to push me forward to the
ground you know and i was trying to push
back up and
they would push me to the ground and
they knew [ __ ] i'm an od
because i felt that before but only to
an extent
it never went and it just kept going you
know that's when you know you're getting
old
when it just keeps going you know always
with heroin there's a certain limit
because you already slammed it you know
that's going to hit that boom
and you're like okay i'm good it's cool
but we're fed on
there is no limit because there is no
rush and that's what i don't understand
people slam heroin because they want the
rush
uh the other [ __ ] don't give you a rush
fentanyl doesn't give you a rush
heroin stays like three to four hours
fentanyl stays for 15 minutes
10 minutes at the most then you got to
get high again
i hear the gentleman that say oh well i
don't [ __ ] roll with needles anymore
i don't poke my vein
anymore yeah you smoke on tinfoil
your bottom poke my veins and hey that's
cool you know because i know once you
poke your veins for so long
they just start hiding they start
disappearing i used to have them
everywhere
you know i was a hyped dream but little
by little as the years passed
they just all went away you know they
all went away and that happens
with drug use you know you're gonna
abuse your body your teeth are gonna
fall out
you're gonna get skinny you get white
hair all that's going to happen
and you know what's going to happen but
yeah you keep going like me i know
what's coming
but i'm welcoming it because i'll keep
going for it you know what i mean and
you know i've doubt drugs all my life
and i can see it and honestly say the
best time in my life
was when i wasn't around drugs when i
didn't deal
drugs i had the most things and they
were all mine and they were all bought
and paid for
i had a brand new car a nice home
and a nice family drugs took all that
away
in a matter of [ __ ] weeks
it just came and just took everything i
had you know i honestly sat there with
everything i said i'm not supposed to be
sitting right here
i'm not supposed to be the guy that's
successful i could sit in his living
room and watch the screen tv
and watch your game on it no i'm not
supposed to be in this position
so i set myself up for failure from the
beginning
i might have put a number there and a
goal and i was going to reach it
but all along i was [ __ ] myself
because
it's a true fact you don't get high on
your own supply
and that's a fact and they say it all
the time i know that that is a fact now
because if i'm gonna do something i
ain't gonna [ __ ] with it
because right there you make money it's
just like life i said the best time in
my life is when i wasn't on drugs
when i wasn't around drugs that was the
best time in my life you know i had the
most things i had the best time
i felt the best and i didn't do one drug
i didn't even take an aspirin
you know but drugs called me back one
thing about drugs is they're
always going to be there they're never
going to go away
they're always going to be there and
there's always going to be another dude
to step up and sing it
they could bust one guy another guy's
going to come in this place
plus these girls more girls are going to
come in their place you know and
the drugs always going to be there it's
like now i got myself official by this
now i got myself a place
by myself i'm finally alone and
it's cold at night sometimes it rains
you know i tell individuals out here on
the streets to go home with me
so they can go to sleep in my house
where it's warm
they refuse to go in the rain
then you got a tent soaking wet and they
don't want to go to me
and i was asking myself why in the [ __ ]
would a [ __ ] not want to go with
me when i'm offering them a shower
a warm bed something to eat and let's
kick it and get high on me
and no they'll stay on the streets
and i asked why and i i found the answer
they gave me the answer
the answer they gave me was they didn't
want to miss
anything that was their answer
they didn't want to miss anything they
still from going to my house and
going kicking back that they're missing
some money or
or some dope that's going to come
they're going to be able to get high on
with so and so
you know they're playing the hope
funeral not the dope fiend road
they're not going to get the dopamine
high they're hoping that someone will
come along
and get them high you know that's a
whole thing you know but
that's the drug thing you know i want to
share a little bit today about it
because
i've been involved in a lot of it and
there's only two things that come out of
drugs and you go to jail for a long last
time or you die
nothing else is going to come from that
you there there are guys that made it to
the top and they're way up there
i bet you they don't sleep comfortable i
know they don't sleep comfortable
they probably owe a lot of money you
know we don't see it but it's probably
in the background
but i just shared because you know i
smoke weed today
in front of anybody wherever it's legal
i wish they would legalize a lot of
drugs
that would eliminate a lot of [ __ ]
but
due to the fact that someone up top
needs their money
drugs ain't going nowhere they're always
going to be here you know it's just
up to you if you're gonna make it a part
of your life i'm not saying to make it a
party life or not to make it a part of
your life
somebody could be a functioning addict
they get high every day and hold a job
and hold a family
and do it until they die more power to
them i can't
once i get high it's about me my family
comes second
you know drugs is first whether i'm
slinging it or i'm doing it
they come first before everybody and
they've been like that i'm gonna sit
here and lie
and tell you that drugs don't come
before my family yes they do
because they're the first ones i think
about in the morning the last thing i
think about going to sleep
and that's what i think about all day
long i don't think about my family when
i go to sleep or when i wake up
through the day sometimes but nah their
second
when it comes to drugs because that drug
is the first thing i want in the morning
that's the first thing i want to see
that's the person you're going to want
to feel that's the first thing you want
to glance back at
when i walk out of my house it's just
that's the way it is and that's what
drugs will do you know so
again you want to get involved in drugs
hey
more power to you i hope the best way i
hope you're the best drug leader in the
world
i hope you get everything you want but
remember as long as that flip side of
the coin
you can enter jail for the rest of your
life or kill the wrong person because of
a bad drug deal
you know there's dudes out there that'll
kill you for an ounce of weed man
you got to be real careful because some
guys are really serious about their
drugs and their money
you know so be careful when you go out
then you start experimenting drugs
remember they're always going to be
there
so you don't have to get involved right
now once you got all your [ __ ] together
and you're 50 years old you've got your
own houses yet
and they get involved in drugs will you
have your own home and you're going to
die in that home
don't do it now now you got to you still
got to go get everything
i wish i would have did that i wish i
would have got everything first
and i just threw my hands up and said
[ __ ] it let's get high now for the rest
of my life boom
it would have been all better like that
but i'm going back and forth you know
i'm still in that fold
well i i encourage anybody i advise
anybody man wait you're like 45 50 if
you're going to get involved in drugs
maybe then by then you won't want to but
get your house and cars and everything
before you do drugs because believe me
if you're going to get housing cars
the georgia's going to take that too and
if the drugs don't take it the cops will
take it
somebody's going to come along and take
it so that's my advice
you know and that's what i got to talk
about they want cool all right john
thank you very much oh yeah
i have two more monk i was i'm writing
them down right now because i want to
get him in my head
you